die im irak entführte deutsche helmes
ist wieder frei darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit bild reporter bernd stritzel
der bei mir hier im studio ist
willkommen björn was weiß man über die
befreiung der kuratoren über die
befreiung wissen wir nur insofern dass
heute den 700 deutscher zeit vom
irakischen militär verkündet wurde dass
er am iwes befreit wurde
bundesaußenminister heiko maas hat sich
vor kurzem auch noch einmal zu wort
gemeldet hat den irakischen behörden
gedankt hat im krisenstab im auswärtigen
amt gejagt haben gedankt die auch daran
mitgearbeitet haben
hella mir wissen zu befreien
beziehungsweise zu lokalisieren und
dergleichen
und das heißt dass sie jetzt in obhut
der deutschen botschaft in bagdad
mittlerweile ist sich den umständen
entsprechend wohlauf seien
was weiß man genaueres zu den entführern
also ist ja bislang hat sich keine
gruppe dazu bekannt zu dieser entführung
kann fraktion offiziell bekannt
allerdings ist mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit davon auszugehen dass
elvis ins visier schiitisch
islamistische milizen gerückt ist durch
ihre arbeit mit mit künstler mit pro
demokratie aktivisten die im vergangenen
herbst demonstrierten gegen gegen
korruption für demokratie im irak und
vor allem gegen den einfluss schiitisch
schiitische islamistische milizen die
unter dem kommando des nachbarlandes
iran stehen diese milizen eine von ihnen
die kts ball heister besonders aktiv im
irak verübt immer wieder anschläge
vergibt raketenangriffe zum beispiel auf
us einrichtungen und der sprecher der
katarer hat auch stunden nach der
entführung von hella mieves auch
verkündet dass seine gruppe eben nicht
dahinter stünde also ganz pro aktiv und
hat den irakischen premierminister
beschuldigt das dass die einführung
seine handschrift die handschrift des
premierministers trüge also ein ganz
absurdes statement was eigentlich darauf
hindeutet dass seine gruppe da
irgendetwas zu verbergen hat heute nach
der freilassung hat dann ein sprecher
dieses schiitischen oder dieses milizen
bündnisses erklärt die irakischen
sicherheitsbehörden also die der
regulären irakischen regierung
unterstützen unterstehen sollten doch
einmal den status von
elvis überprüfen wie könne es sein dass
sie im geheimen wie er sich ausgedrückt
hat gearbeitet hätte also die frau aus
kulturvermittlerin da ist nichts geheim
oder so aber er hat versucht zu zu
suggerieren sie hätte da irgendwie als
eine art spion oder sowas gearbeitet das
deutet darauf hin dass hella mir ist
eins in die mühlen der irakischen
politik geraten ist zwischen diese
zwischen dieser schiitisch diese
mächtigen schiitischen milizen
einerseits den großen einfluss auf die
sicherheits architektur im irak haben
großen einfluss auf die irakische
politik haben und eben auf der anderen
seite die irakische regierung vor allem
unter dem neuen premier vladimir ein
gutes verhältnis hat zu deutschland und
der versucht sich diesen wachsenden
iranischen einfluss ein wenig entgegen
zu stellen dass dieses medizin bündnis
hat wenn wir davon ausgehen sie entführt
und ein wenig druck auf den
premierminister auszügen hier am montag
wurde hella mevis entführt jetzt ist sie
wieder frei bin vielen herzlichen dank
für deine einschätzung zu diesem fall